i used to do these tricks i used to be
like a driver
and with a girl and people would always
say we want two girls
and what i just said was [ __ ] it man you
know i'm just getting dragged and i just
show up as another girl and that's all i
did so you would turn tricks with a
regular female yeah and we would just go
see the guy and you know we would do
whatever the hell we're going to do with
the guy you're in dragon she's yeah and
the guy would be like i don't care it's
a girl i don't care if it's a trans last
night i don't give a [ __ ] come on let's
do the trick
[Laughter]
all right jamie where'd you grow up um
in the east coast okay
[Laughter]
so so when did you get started with this
whole lifestyle um 1993
what happened was
i just couldn't um
i just couldn't find a girlfriend i'd
get lucky and every now and then i was
like
like in my late 20s and i couldn't
really find a girlfriend you know i'd
get lucky once in a blue moon of course
you know but i wouldn't get a girlfriend
that would stay alone
and
um what happened was
i started meeting these girls that i
knew they were tricking and i wanted to
kind of get in on the action
and um i got myself a beeper
and i was tricking as a man you know as
a dude
and then i started
you know i started befriending girls
just getting more and more closer to
girls and then i started dressing up and
then actually what happened was i would
go to like like an alternative club and
i'd start getting closer and closer to
these girls and i would um i'd get
closer and closer to them
and i started driving them around to do
escorts
and uh
i started tricking with them and guys
would call and say you know i want two
girls and it's hard enough finding one
hard enough i need one and you'll be
lucky to find one you can't get two
you're not gonna get that lucky and then
bring them both there and they're you
know if you did they're both going to be
dopes and one of them's going to be dope
sick
you know and
and that's just the way the cookie
crumbles
and uh
what i started doing was i would tell
them look
why don't we uh
do the two girls special thing i'm not
getting dragged most of the girls i
would always just i would always uh
surprise them
they'd get in that car and i'd be
dressed as a woman
and that's all there is to it and i
would say look we're going to go do this
with two girls and
when she'd getting that card after using
that phone
i'd be in drive
and
you know it would just work you would
change quickly
you would change quickly quickly you
know i'll just sort of damn makeup on
i would uh
what i would do is i'd uh surprise them
with hey you're meeting jamie
yeah and uh we would do our thing
go do the call and
that's all
you know i ended up
just uh
you know and i never thought i was going
to end up in a in a relationship i was
in three relationships with different
dancers
and uh
and i started tricking it was 93 started
tricking as a transvestite with these
girls that were dancers
slash you know escorts
and one after another we just you know
would always be different girls you know
but i got it down to like about 12 of
them that i you know did escorts with
and uh
we had fun i'm gonna say i'd be lying if
i did said i did not have fun
i didn't uh like the drugs the fact of
the matter was i didn't really do any
drugs
but
i was
more concerned with uh
you know the girls and their safety and
stuff
and that's what it was
that's how it happened
and uh
you know
where do you think this fascination with
this
came from
oh well the fascination came from um
what was your childhood like
um
it was fun because you ever hear of the
the song by linda ronstadt the devil in
disguise
uh my own uh family german shepherd dog
almost bit me
i came running out of my room one night
and i'd swiped a credit card from
somebody i don't even know who i stole
the credit card from
you're you're hold oh my god maybe 24 i
don't know okay and uh i swiped the
credit card called these girls i didn't
have a car they're coming to get me with
a car
and uh
and i came running out of that bedroom
and i wanted to see i kind of thought
that the dog wouldn't recognize me and
he was up in this little window in the
house like where he was sitting and he
hopped off that floor and
slid across the tile floor and showed me
his teeth like i was a total stranger
like i was a burglar
and that was funny this is your dog well
yeah i was our family dog yeah
pretty good-sized dog
and he would have bit me i had to stop
and yell his name
and uh
and then he stopped and he realized
i recognized the voice but i don't
recognize the person i looked like
elvira you know like kind of like a
you know
and oh you're dressed up yeah because i
do all my clothes on through my makeup
on
and yeah the girls were right in the car
outside we jumped in the car and it was
a lady's id
that's what it was it was a lady's id
that i stole
and a lot of times i would never tell
the peop tell the girls
that i was kind of encouraged with the
with the store clerks
and i would tell the girls don't joke
around
and you know because if you say anything
and you're on camera and you're stealing
somebody's freaking id
you know
and you know the cops might go back and
say you know look we got you guys on
camera and you're laughing and joking
around you guys must have knew these
people
you know
so i would never really say too much to
them i would go in and try to uh
do it as quick as possible
and you know rent all kinds of crazy
stuff
and then they would never see it again
but what were your parents like
what were your parents like
oh and they passed away of your
childhood like when you were when you
were young um under 10 what was it like
oh it was pretty brutal
yeah
uh typical typical um
the typical kind of lifestyle when
you're a kid and uh one of the parents
is gone
you know what i mean uh
and uh hey it is what it is but i still
survived that's the bottom line no abuse
sexual abuse anything like that
oh well the other kids were just wrong
to me
you know
the older ones because it was a little
that was a little bit of the younger
side of the other kids
you know
[Music]
but uh
[Music]
you know that's just the way it goes you
knew you had this fascination early uh
yeah and i knew that
you know that's the way you're certain
you got to survive you know you got to
track your trick you know most of the
times when you're doing escorts though
you don't have to do [ __ ] usually the
guys the people want to just have you
hang out with them
and they're so fascinated with having a
couple of girls there
they don't expect you to do too much
you know
like if it's an escort job
they'll want you to sit there and get
high with them
you know
and i'll tell you what when i did small
crack i said poof i could puff on it i'd
be like hey i'm glad i didn't pay for it
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you know i never really had um
an addiction drugs are not your thing
drugs are not my thing no but i tell you
what i will do ecstasy with a girl if i
got a chance to do ecstasy
because i did actually see a few times
with girls and uh my girl had max matter
of fact turned me on to it
and extra key is awesome
and i will do ecstasy if i get a chance
and i will like it
if it's what if i'm doing it with a girl
you know
because they could be like heterosexual
with a girl
when you're bisexual you get the best of
both worlds
so you like
with men and women oh hell yeah
yeah that's just the way the cookie
crumbles i mean i will make no excuses
for being bisexual i am not going to
make an excuse
i'm just not
i won't
[ __ ] that why should i you like to you
like to do this how often
yeah but i'm i'm realizing i'm not
passable
you know i don't want to do it if i'm
not passing it
i don't want to do it if i'm not
possible
but taking taking the hormones and
surgery no i never did that [ __ ] no i
wasn't into that
no so i just didn't like it because um
because i like [ __ ] too much
you know plain english
you know i mean you know i might have i
might do something with a guy but that's
for money
you know so i remember i had people tell
me you know obviously you could be boss
but you're not really you're not really
doing it for the
because you want a relationship
you know i don't want a relationship
with a guy or a relationship for a girl
actually would i want a relationship
with several girls
you
know and
so a female turns you on more than a
male oh definitely with males you can
make money with yeah man
[Laughter]
thank you very much a man i can make
money with but uh
the female's not going to pay you for
anything no
probably not impending
having to do [ __ ]
they want to get paid actually
that's right you know
and i used to joke with my girlfriend
heather because she used to have sex and
i said tell her i got to get paid honey
and she used to believe me
she used to really believe me and i'd be
like baby you don't ever have to pay me
yeah she'll deed [ __ ] sick sad really
sad she had a really wicked
drug problem
and i really believe there's good drugs
on this world and there's bad ones
crack and heroin are terrible
you know
i will say that much because they
you know people will d on it what the
[ __ ] you know
and
see i could do my makeup without a
mirror
and it's kind of funny because i i'm
used to doing it behind the wheel of a
car
and i've never used a mirror i'd be like
hey what do i need a mirror for
you know when i'm you know
i'm just going to run in there with some
makeup on some as long as you smell good
then i've had guys tell me that as long
as you smell good and you're kind of you
know dark uh
you're not gonna really see them so
being a woman is more of a financial
thing for you oh yeah definitely you can
you find you can make good money being a
being a [ __ ] yeah right yeah and what
how i started was by stealing credit
cards that were older women that looked
kind of like a school teacher and i
figure hey look you're up to doing
something no good you're up to no good i
had the chance to swipe your pocketbook
and you didn't have a chance to realize
your pocketbook was gone until you came
back a couple days later if i had a
couple of days to use your credit card
too [ __ ] bad
you know so you're a hustler oh yeah
and back then you know you didn't have
insurance on your credit cards
you did not have insurance on your
credit card so if you were burnt if that
credit card was racked up for ten
thousand dollars you were [ __ ]
is there any enjoyment in being a woman
for you oh yeah you enjoy it as well
yeah i'll enjoy it yeah i'll enjoy the
sex
i'll enjoy it yeah i'm not gonna say i
don't enjoy it you're bisexual like you
said yeah yeah
but i don't want a relationship
with a guy i want a relationship with a
girl you've been in love before oh yeah
with girls they were in love with me
thank you very much for a question like
that
and the women know that you do this on
the side oh yeah i let everyone know off
the rip
you got to let them know hey look first
i'll go to them and say look i need to
know some are you a little bi and they
always say of course in this day and age
in this day and age any woman is going
to be
100 honest and i'll be like if you're
not bi
um i really don't want to you know
horse around with her you know because
she looked down on a guy that's by you
know she would look down at a guy that's
a hustler
you know because i'm a hustler and i
always meet girls that are dancers
they're a dancer as a hustler
and it's very few and far between to
meet a dancer
that is um drug-free
usually i'll meet a dancer and she's
going to be uh
you know somebody that's on drugs
and that's sad you know because i'd
rather be with the girl that was
definitely not on drugs you know
and it makes the relationship really
hard
you know
yeah
manhattan's a good city for this
lifestyle right what's that manhattan's
a good city for this oh yeah
yeah there's something for everybody
here right
it's definitely good for for you know
for drag and
stuff like that yeah
yeah it's not like uh it's not like
you're gonna go to like minnesota or
something so your clients are on the
down low or they're just
you know that would just be a guy that
would be calling for two girls
and then they'd get a surprise when a
[ __ ] shows up and a girl and they'd be
like come on [ __ ] it come
you know on don't care
i want people on two worlds
as far as i'm concerned you're a girl
and that's just the way the cookie would
crumble
you know because they're looking for a
good time yeah they're looking for a
good time we would show them a good time
and uh
and they'd have their good time they'd
be happy they'd give me the money and
they wouldn't care you know
and that's just the way the cookie
crumbles
so
how often will you do this a week um
like uh two three times a week really
yeah
and i'll tell you what i did it where we
would drive alcohol
and then i did it where we would have a
motel and i've also did it from a house
and all three are always different
scenarios
when you're doing it in a house
um you have a little bit more control
over the person who comes to see you
because they're terrified
and uh
a lot of times they'll just hand over
the money and i don't like to do that
but it just happened
a lot of times is you know
i was kind of a [ __ ] [ __ ] about it
i'll admit it
and i would take the money and wouldn't
do [ __ ]
and i didn't like doing that but i did
and you know a lot of times the first
thing the guy would say was do you have
tits and i'd say sure i got tits yeah i
got tits or um
yeah here i got tits you want tits here
you go
there you go buddy
you say you want tits okay
there you go
i got tits so now when i'd come to their
house
the guy would be like you told me you
had tits
and be like yeah i told you they were
fake
i told you they were fake though
and they'd be like what the [ __ ]
you're like well that's what you i told
you you said and they would say i wanted
real tips i wouldn't be like mister if
you wanted real kids you should have
called for a girl
you should have called for a girl what
kind of reactions have you had when you
show up and you were you're not quite
well just leave and take the money and
they'd be like you [ __ ] you know they
can't start you know they'd be just so
because they're you know their neighbors
and you know the family members were
like neighbors and they didn't want
anybody to know they don't want to cause
a problem they had a prostitute in the
house let alone it was a man
you know they'd be like [ __ ] it i'm
probably going to be divorced if i cause
a problem too embarrassing for them i
remember one night i left with 175
dollars in heart for
on a guy and he said i wanted tits i
said well you got tits
you know
and uh
oh well
lol
that's that uh old thing about lol
you know
so your first
your first effort to be a woman was
inspired by money or by
the desire to be a woman oh money
definitely
definitely i was doing it for money
oh yeah i was definitely doing it for
money and it's nice that i'm doing this
interview putting on my makeup telling
you about it
huh
did you ever stand and look at what
you're doing and go jesus christ what am
i doing
did you ever question what you're what
you're doing
uh no
i liked it i wanted the money
i've had guys uh chicken out a lot of
times they were chicken out
they would give me the money
i remember the first time a guy called
me i came to the motel room and he said
i'm not going to do this i can't go
through with it and he chickened out he
hands me the money and i called the
escort service that i was working for
and i said the guy handed me the money
and he said well you better get used to
that honey the girl the girl on the
other end of the phone
you know she said you better get
um very used to that because guys will
chicken out
and that's just the way to the cookie
crumbles
you know like if i knew where there was
a bar like
between a gay bar and a strip bar
i would probably prefer to go into a
strip bar tonight
i'll tell you why
because the dancers are way more
friendly
and
i probably get lucky
and meet a nice stripper
i thought i was pretty fun
and she would say you know maybe i'll
give you my number if i can get lucky
one more time in life
that's what happened she'll have an open
mind
yeah if i meet an open-minded stripper
that's like if i tell her hey look
because that's how i met like i was in
like three relationships you'll be at
the strip club dressed as a woman that's
a girl
that's a [ __ ] girl
and uh
the dancers would be like hey you seem
pretty cool
yeah
and that's that's the way the cookie
would crumble
that's
the way the cookie would crumble
so
yeah
that's just the way the cookie would
crumble
but i went to amsterdam
and i told my girl that i would sell my
[ __ ] soul to the devil for her
and um
she was like
uh impressed
that i loved her that much
and when i say sell myself to the devil
i'm catholic
okay
and i meant it
it's not like i met a joke it's not like
a teenage joke
that was not a teenage joke by saying
that
you know what i mean
you were in love what's that you were in
love with her
oh yeah i was definitely in love with
her all the girls that i uh kind of
tricked with pretty much i cared about
if not loved
you know what i mean
probably loved i'd say
probably would say these are working
girls oh yeah these are work girls
but i would still go down on them
and i wouldn't care
and that's just the way it would when
you love a woman you're gonna
you know
do whatever you do with them
and i love them and i lusted them and
they knew it
and a woman will tell can tell when you
lust her
because i had told this one girl
she had to have four or five boyfriends
and i was like
one but i wasn't the number one i had
told the number one boyfriend
or well he wasn't really her number one
he was like her
because i knew her her
her number one was well she had like six
of them there was the one that um we
never seen
right he was a kid that was totally
straight we never seen him
he was like her number one boyfriend
and then there was this other guy
and then there was like um
number three number three boyfriend i
told him you better you better take her
and suck her ass as hard as you can and
try your best to suck her brains out of
her head and suck her heart out and her
soul out of her
and he went back and he told her he said
jamie told me to do this to you
and uh
that's just something the guy does when
he left the woman
you know
believe me
i think all of us lusted her
and we all argued with her until she odd
and every now and then i'll go and put a
couple of roses on her grave
and by the way that's yellow roses
because she was really a friend
and if anybody knows what it's like
to be a friend is when you're a girl's
tricking partner
you know what i mean
you know because really you got her back
then and they know it
you know they know they're not gonna
let nobody you're not gonna let anybody
hurt them
and now you're a woman
well
not exactly
but this is how you present yourself
yeah as a female yeah
and people
well guys will trick with me yeah
and especially when i'm with a girl
they'll be like oh hell yeah i
definitely want to trick with you
there's some alternative lifestyles out
there
yeah
that's because guys are bored they're
bored they're drunk
they're doing coke they figure oh come
on
i always wanted to do something with a
transfer you know
like [ __ ] it
now i got a chance to
you know
and they do it
and you enjoy this lifestyle you have
fun with it
yeah i do and you're making money with
it i'd be lying if i said i wasn't
i'd be lying if i said i wasn't
you know i was in like three of
relationships with three different girls
and we did this
so why can't i look for a number number
four yeah you know your childhood was it
was
tell me about that again well it was
kind of uh appalachian you know i gotta
say it was poor yeah where'd you grow up
uh in the east coast okay but it was it
was you know like you know if you had a
bike you had a stolen bike
you know if you had a car you had a
stolen car
if you had a car you had an unregistered
car
what comes first
it sounds like being a hustler is what
you are at heart yeah right because
you're trying to make money yeah and i'm
not into drugs because if you're going
to do drugs then you're really going to
have nothing
yeah
and you know once you get a taste of
having a nice car having a nice
apartment having a [ __ ]
hot crazy girlfriend
you know
especially a couple of them
and you end up with a team you end up
with a baseball team
and that's nice when you have a baseball
team of girls that are like hey look
we'll steal all the credit cards we'll
you know we'll do all kinds of [ __ ] the
hustle guys so these girls are hustlers
you're a hustler yeah right and the real
goal is to get money yeah a lot of money
whether it's for sex or getting credit
cards or watches or
right it was usually credit cards never
[ __ ] watches because watches are like
you're always going to steal the timex
so that's that's goes beyond unless
you're gonna you know the guy owns a
rolex
and uh you know but the thing was to
grab a credit card
and you know if you knew if you knew
that the guy knew that if you knew that
he knew that he had a wife
and he was um
he was like
hey look what do i got to do to give you
guys money to get rid of you just to get
rid of you guys
you know
but i mean let's say you came into a
bunch of money where you didn't need to
hustle anymore
you let's say a sugar daddy he came
along and just thought you were the [ __ ]
and just is gonna oh i would probably be
where i'm at on felt life you'd still be
doing it no but i wouldn't be tricking
for money and i stopped doing it for
money but would you still be dressing up
as a woman
yeah to have fun with guys yeah because
you can always hustle a guy
you can and once you get into drag i'm
going to tell you right now once you're
a
a girl
and you got a transvestite and you're
together you can act like you don't even
know the person you can tell the girl
look go to the bar that i'm gonna go to
in which i did i used to do this all the
time i would tell a girl go to the
[ __ ] bar and i'll make believe i
don't even know you
and the guy would take me to the bar for
a drink and this is what we did one of
the very first times we did this
um we're at the bar where make them
believe we don't know each other and the
guy he can't take his eyes off of the
girl
she's the only girl in the bar it was a
gay bar
and i mean a gay bar a dingy gay bar one
horse town bar i don't need to mention
any names
and we're in there and he can't take his
you know his eyes off of this pretty
girl he can't keep his eyes off of her
she goes in the bathroom and he goes go
in the bathroom ask that girl if she
wants to they'll come home with us
and i said i'm not going to ask her and
i know her of course but i'm not telling
him i know her i said give me the money
up front and then what if she throws a
drink in my face
right and um
he gives me the money and i go in the
bathroom and i tell him tell her he gave
me the money we're gonna go home with
him and uh you know just act like we
don't know each other and we're we kept
asking each other what our names were
you know so we kept playing it off that
we didn't know each other
you know
and you took the guy for how much money
at the end of the day it was 200 bucks
and we split 100 bucks a piece and it
was fun
you know just to go to the bar
you know what i mean
because what i would always do with a
guy who wanted to meet a transvestite i
would tell him go get a motel room and
it would always be close to where i
lived and i would tell them get the room
and then go to the strip bar
leave the key with the either the um
you know the um front desk and tell them
your friend jamie's coming to pick up
the key
and he would say well you know because
it's kind of like a gay endeavor uh they
would feel a little uncomfortable and
they would say look i'm gonna leave the
key or the credit card that you use to
get in the room and they would say i'm
gonna leave it in the mat under the door
you know under the front door of the
motel room
and uh they would i'd go to the room and
i'd get dressed because
you know living the lifestyle as a
type of a thug guy you don't want your
friends or neighbors to see you leaving
your house you have a straight job
during the day yeah i live as a straight
guy do you have a job i work for myself
i'm a hustler i'm kind of like a hustler
there too and a lot of times i've come
across
that's how i kind of met my girl one of
my girlfriends the one that'll deed um i
told her i said it seems weird because
a lot of customers will ask me what
other kind of work do you do
on a friday and here it is it's friday
get rid of the goddamn contractors at
your house and say good goodbye i'll
show them out of here they start asking
me crazy questions like what kind of
other tools do you have
and i'd kind of pick up on it and they'd
say can you go get a girl for us
and i'd say i can go get a girl i'd just
go walk into a [ __ ] strip bar and try
to hit one of the girls and i had said
this to this girl at the time it was
like 10 years ago i told her i laid an
honor i said you know here let's sit
down have a drink and i put a 20 bill in
front of her i said let's have a drink
and i said you know i want to ask you
first of all are you bi she said yes i
am and i said well look i'm bi and i get
people left and right asking me
would you uh do a two girl special with
us you know in a transvestite or even a
guy you know just me as a boy you know
and
you know she said hell yeah she gives me
a bunch of phone numbers
and i thought it was the coolest thing
in the world
you know and
you know i'm just grateful that
that i'm not the father of that baby
that she owed with a seven month old
baby
and i am grateful to god that i'm not
the father because i'd have to be
raising a uh a baby
without a mother
and
i mean other women could play the role
as a mother
but no one's going to really play the
role actual is mommy the way mommy will
really do it
and be there for that kid 60 years later
and that's sad i mean there's some
things that are fun but there's a lot of
things that are happening in this
lifestyle that are very tragic
and drugs you might think you're gonna
rule the world and do this [ __ ] but once
drugs get into the middle of it and they
think oh yeah i like to see you you
think you're gonna have fun you're gonna
have the most miserable night of the
night of the of your life
and when the girls on drugs you will
have the most miserable life
night of your life
you will you just will you know you'll
get pistol whipped you'll you know
you'll be buying drugs and you you know
the guy that's supposed to be there
isn't there because he's probably
probably got robbed and probably got a
bunch of thugs where i beat him up and
you know it's just it's it's terrible
you know because somebody else will be
there with that telephone and he's going
to rob you too
and that's just the way the cookie
crumbles
so if you think it's fun
it is not
it is definitely not you might have some
fun
um
is it worth it no because you could just
be trying to
find a girl that doesn't do any drugs
and finding a girl that doesn't do any
drugs
uh are very hard to find
and um that's just the way the cookie
crumbles
you know what i mean
all right jamie thank you for
letting us watch you get dressed
and telling us about your i think that's
where we should end yeah your
interesting lifestyle okay thank you so
much
you